[Aplausos]
bom dia
acham francisca os verdes ou no
instituto superior técnico
quero representar o tema da poluição a
constância universitário estão sujeitos
no título pronto agora já vem o título
bomba ea versão não sou palavras com o
filme o bom o mau eo vilão neste caso é
onde pensava cavalo está na hora de todo
vilão dessa história mas cada vez mais
têm dúvidas em relação a isso
pra mim a oposição tem um papel fulcral
na forma como nós aprendemos o que quer
que seja
o que fez a abordar esse tema foi fazer
muitas conversas em curva 12 e vários
amigos meus isso porque estava mal na
coleção mas nunca fizemos nada em
relação a isso
penso que a responsabilidade está nos
ombros ao mesmo tempo existe um certo
conformismo que é passada de geração em
geração
no qual aplicamos aquilo que nós foi
feito apesar de discordarmos e avança
mantendo se nos mesmos moldes pra mim é
com as costas na cabeça às vezes pensa
será que a única ser outra única pensar
que algo está mal por um dos estudantes
e outros tantos não estão cá nunca
pensaram foram mal avaliados o advogado
forma injusta
tenho certeza que muitos estudantes
sentiram assim no passado e no presente
tamanho também também tem uma edição que
outras estatísticas como os funcionários
das unidades curriculares kanú técnico
são muito importantes possam dizer o
contrário o que faltou experiência
própria e pensa que é relevante porque
as estatísticas nem sempre são
esclarecedoras
afinal de contas penso eu o que é a
versão uma definição mais simples de
dacca avaliação é um processo de recolha
de informação e de acordo com critérios
definidos tomada a decisão parece muito
simples mas a oposição hoje em dia é
usada para como uma ferramenta montana
quadrada o tipo por um rota uma forma de
um número uma pessoa uma tabela num
teste isto é classificar
não é vulgar então qual é o objetivo da
avaliação
segundo alguns autores que subscrevo o
objetivo da oposição é o de apoiar a
aprendizagem por causa da eleição
aprendizagem ensino são todos
interligados que só faz sentido nos
conectarmos o objetivo final que é o
homem aprender
a forma que nós verificamos isso
realmente acontece a poluição forma a
forçar esta treta que o objetivo da
avaliação é o de apoiar a aprendizagem
que ajustar alguns estados dos testes
visando os três filhos são os testes
realizados mundialmente mais de 30
países ao longo de 15 anos rapazes e
raparigas são testes que abordam os
temas leitura ciência e matemática
este é o topix a isso sacou as partes
relacionadas e dos proprietários dos 30
países na coluna top é a porcentagem de
alunos descida da tsu que está acima da
média a porcentagem de alunos lentos
nesse país
na coluna loeb vantagens alunos que
estão abaixo da média os maus alunos ou
mais sua performance o que seria dessa
tabela é de uma boa educação não é
aquela que se foca somente os meus
alunos mas aquela que perante todos os
alunos progridam
é um caso muito específico aqui que é o
caso do vietnã
como podem ver tem uma posição favorável
nesta tabela apesar de terem poucos
alunos lentes
eu estou afirmando como é que conseguem
ter essa posição
eles fazem isso porque compensa o fato
um pouco em alguns lances com o fato e
também poucos alunos baixa performance
esse clube da luz desta posição
favorável do outro lado do espectro está
a frança está mais abaixo
a frança tem muitos alunos residência o
que é estranho estamos mais confiantes
na não faz sentido eu sou do estado para
esta posição por também tem muitos
alguns estão abaixo da média
isso cria uma certa determinado um certo
nível entre os alunos
qualquer como incluir aqui em prática
todos concordamos que o objetivo da
fundação é mesmo apoio à aprendizagem
muitas vezes ao falar com colegas e
amigos que condição de que passamos mais
tempo de curar conceito sacramentos
resolução aprender as manhas a fazer
exercícios do que possamos encontrar o
conhecimento da nossa vida estudando
nosso futuro
a culpa não é nossa a culpa não é nossa
por termos regularmente expostas a um
tipo de coleção cujo objetivo é
classificar e nós vamos adaptar se
tiverem um teste tipo
nós vamos melhorar naquilo sp foi o
melhor possível nós adaptamos para
sermos mais eficientes com nosso tempo
ou três anos o tempo da melhor forma
possível
temos a melhor nota e isso muitas
pessoas não se observa
o fato como uma reunião a forma como
alguns alunos influencia diretamente a
forma como estudam e aprendem e crescem
com o futuro queria desviar um caso
destas emissões iniciais e abordaram um
ativo escrito por um senhor chamado
michael vai fãs mais relevantes foi um
professor não é marketing
depois vai para o técnico o professor
convidado este guia 2001 eo conde está
tive a minha cabeça spud os meus
neurônios andaram mais de cem à hora
porque aí vai que estático companheiro
tom pessoal era tão próprio meu próprio
pensamento e ao mesmo tempo era um ponto
mas como fazer a opção tivessem sido
escritas por um professor estrangeiro há
mais de 15 anos
vou juntar alguns do serviço enquanto
agora a idéia geral da infância e
juventude com 2 com sites que a
avaliação pontual ea evolução contínua é
pontual é mais comum é que está neste
serviço
são dois a três testes que são
realizados no semestre um exame e
determinada estabilidade mostra uma
parte da nota
isso encoraja muito o pânico arnim aqui
um franzido aprendendo à altura dos
desafios na realidade não vai aprender
ao mesmo tempo é existe outra feita
avaliação pontual que é o fato de ser
uma grande densidade de matéria é muito
difícil fazer um teste equilibrados
quanto à matéria três meses um exame
o que acontece muito provavelmente é que
uma certa parte da matéria não vai ser
abordada vai ser recordada comenta
profundidade
isso quer dizer que a avaliação podem
nem sequer apresentar na totalidade o
que foi mais erro foi acionado durante
as aulas
eu pergunto essa informação é válida é
como se fosse uma mostra que é
inadequada e que está contaminada logo à
partida no próximo certo
quero estar no próximo de ser diferente
ela evidencia que o crescimento da
coleção implica um pouco menos feedback
que o feedback é importante porque é o
feedback o feedback é importante porque
aumenta em que o professor pode ser o
aluno os erros que o fez e está fazendo
por duas razões a primeira é quase
intuitiva ou não intenção dos erros com
teu tensão matérias é ter mais
dificuldades e o que pode mudar no seu
método de tudo
a segunda razão não tão intuitiva é
comprar
o professor pode usar essa informação
para os aula saber em que parte com os
alunos têm mais dificuldades e adaptar o
seu método de ensino o professor
caso queira escrever um método de
avaliação contínua em várias revoluções
por semestre
até pode utilizar diferentes diferentes
ferramentas da coleção que quer dizer
pode fazer coleções em grupo e
individuais projetos fiz laboratório
isso leva a que haja uma versão mais
completa seja mais representativa e
também fala em conta aquela idéia de que
a poluição o ensino e aprendizagem estão
todos interligados pensa agora estas
noções já estão bastante definidas e
seria muito positivo para mim se fosse
possível mudar a mentalidade de alguns
alunos e professores para que
conquistássemos mais na avaliação
contínua que eu penso em grandes
benefícios mudar a mentalidade das
pessoas é muito difícil e custa custa
porque exige que nós temos admitido que
cometemos erros no passado tanto as
pessoas como os alunos e que nada
fizemos em relação a isso
penso que essa é uma das principais
barreiras não queremos dar hoje em dia
esta situação me situação jurídica está
no país no artigo michael fãs e por mais
que me custe dizer penso que é uma
realidade recorrente aproveitar o último
serviço para dar um passo no que pode
ser a versão no futuro
hoje em dia os desafios estão
enquadrados num certo para bimba desta
sociedade e é muito simples
hoje em dia essa neste paradigma que é a
poluição é muito distinto do que era no
passado tem que ser muito simples que é
passada a informação é bunda antes a
partirem santo com as constantes sabemos
fazer bem avaliado esta geração nos
moldes da anterior em que o cenário era
diferente em comum estava tudo
segmentados a gestão do hoje em dia
informação da ponta dos dedos as
capacidades há 50 anos atrás mas quero
mais preciosas já não são as de hoje em
dia os alunos têm de ser capazes de
filtrar a informação para os aula ser
crítico em relação ao que aprendem
também têm de ser capazes de aprender a
aprender ea pensar de forma independente
isso é muito importante para
conseguirmos ser criativos e incisivos
no futuro
eu penso não são estas as capacidades
nós temos em investir hoje em dia
ao desenvolver nós quer refletir
portanto deixe o tema é aberto à
discussão pública porque no final do dia
todas as conversas começam nos cursos
obrigado
[Aplausos]